Silently passing through the inky void of
space, a vessel was hurriedly making its way
towards its destination.
The craft was sleek, designed and built by
hands not of this world.
Aboard, one of the occupants knelt before
its elders: it was time.
It gathered its arsenal in a methodical, almost
ceremonial fashion; its spear latched onto
its back with its survival gear, a MediKit,
containing surgical equipment and specialized
serums.
It donned its gauntlets, then reached for
the final piece: its mask, that it slipped
over its face.
Ready for its task, the creature boarded a
smaller scout ship, which was jettisoned and
began to descend towards the planet below:
a world known as ‘Earth’.
On the surface of the planet itself, a technician
was sitting at his desk, bored, staring at
readouts from satellites and the endless sweeping
of a radar, scanning the skies above for any
signs of disturbance.
For a moment, as the scout craft passed through
the atmosphere, something happened that broke
the technician out of his boredom.
There was a blip on the radar, the tiny detection
of an unknown signal, that of an object traveling
on a direct course through the sky.
Just as the technician started to take notice,
the approaching ship activated a stealth mechanism,
reflecting all light away from it in order
to render it almost invisible, while simultaneously
becoming undetectable to radar.
The blip vanished from the screen and didn’t
reappear.
The technician shrugged, thinking it was probably
nothing but an equipment glitch; besides,
the SCP Foundation didn’t pay him enough
to follow up on every tiny blip.
A few hours later, and several continents
away, a Mobile Task Force was on an assignment.
The oppressive heat and humidity of the Lacandon
Jungle was bearing down on them; especially
in their combat gear, the operatives were
all feeling unbearably hot.
The Foundation researchers overseeing the
MTF’s mission via satellite didn’t have
to contend with the elements in the comfort
of their air-conditioned command center.
But little did they or their boots on the
ground know, there was something else visiting
the rainforest too.
It had been stalking the squad for a few miles
now, and not one of them had noticed…
just as the creature planned.
A trio of red laser beams cast three distinct
dots over one of the MTF operative’s chest…
Suddenly, a streak of energy shot through
the air, crackling as it struck the agent,
tearing through his chest and killing him
on the spot.
Instinctively, the remaining troops turned
and opened fire at the treetop where the blast
had come from, spraying a volley of bullets
enough to start shredding the wood of the
tree, splinters, and bark raining down.
They hit nothing, there was no sign of whoever
or whatever had fired that shot and killed
their teammate.
From behind them, a pair of discs with a row
of long, fan-like blades around their edge
flew through the air.
There was so much force behind the arm that
threw them that the pair of shuriken lifted
two of the remaining MTF soldiers off their
feet and impaled them to the trunks of nearby
trees.
The last remaining Foundation operative looked
at the bodies of his dead squad mates in horror,
before turning and fleeing.
But just as he ran for his life, something
caught him.
It was transparent, cloaked, and near-impossible
to see, but it had plunged a pair of blades
into the MTF troop’s chest, lifting him
off his feet with ease as he screamed in pain.
An invisible, leathery-skinned hand reached
for his throat and twisted, and in an instant,
with a sickening crack, the man was silent,
dropped limply to the floor.
From the command center, watching in awe as
this imperceptible monster tore through four
of their finest operatives with ease, a pair
of researchers turned to look at each other.
The expressions they both wore were faces
of sheer disbelief; they had both heard the
stories, instantly recognizing the destructive
behavior.
But never thought they’d see – or not
see – it carried out for real.
“We still don’t have a name for them,
do we?”
Researcher Hall asked as the pair of them
walked briskly down the corridor.
“Negative,” replied his counterpart, Researcher
DiLiegro.
“But the files we acquired from military
intelligence suggest that they’ve been coming
to Earth for decades.
Centuries even, the earliest known encounter
took place in the 1700s.”
“Can we negotiate with this one at all?”
Hall asked, fully expecting the answer.
“I don’t think they respond well to that
kind of engagement,” DiLiegro said.
“They seemingly come to Earth with one singular
purpose: to hunt.”
“For sport?”
“It seems so.”
“What about their capabilities?”
the senior researcher pressed.
“Their technology is pretty advanced, even
compared to some of the things we’ve seen,”
the other explained.
“On top of that, they’re fast, strong,
and completely ruthless.
Pretty much an apex predator.
According to intel, the instances of these
creatures that have previously visited Earth
have displayed a sort of… tribal nature.”
“Care to elaborate?”
Hall probed.
“Based on the files, their hunts seem partially
recreational.
But also like some kind of ritual, to prove
themselves as capable or to challenge themselves.”
“That gives me an idea,” the researcher
replied.
“Contact Containment Area 25b.
If we play this right, we can bag one of these
creatures and bring it in for testing.”
***
Time seemed to race by as Hall and DiLiegro
were bundled aboard a transport and taken
directly to Containment Area 25b; a facility
built by the Foundation specifically to house
a particularly dangerous anomaly.
Within the hour, the two researchers were
standing facing a huge stone cube, its dark
surface sporting a number of symbols engraved
into it.
Growing impatient, knowing their window of
opportunity was rapidly closing, Hall turned
to one of the Foundation personnel stationed
within the Primary Containment Zone around
SCP-076.
“Play it again,” he instructed.
“Wake him up.”
Hitting a button, a recorded message began
to play over the facility’s loudspeakers.
It had been translated into an ancient Sumerian
dialect that the entity within the stone cube
had historically shown a preference for.
“Come on out,” the message stated.
“We know you don’t think any of us are
worth your time.
But we remember Omega Seven.
You’ve agreed to work with us before, even
though you don’t think we present enough
of a challenge to you.
But we may have found something that will.
An adversary that you could have the privilege
of besting in combat.”
There was a brief moment of silence, before
the stone began to rumble.
The security personnel on site tensed up,
gripping their weapons in shaky, nervous hands.
Slowly, the circular lock on the side of the
cube began twisting, the door it kept sealed
beginning to open.
“Are you sure we can do this, Hall?” asked
DiLiegro.
“If SCP-076 isn’t willing to cooperate,
this could go south really quickly.
And god forbid, what if somebody found out
what we’re having him do?”
Hall didn’t answer, instead watching as
the door to the cube finally opened, and a
lean man in his late twenties stepped out.
His grey eyes stared out under a mess of jet
black hair, his body adorned with tattoos
of arcane runes and occult imagery, the sneering
faces of demons, over his olive skin.
As the guards around him nervously raised
their weapons at the ready, SCP-076-2 casually
strode up to Researcher Hall, until the two
were inches away from each other.
“Where?”
Able asked.
Fitting him with a communication earpiece
and having him board a transport, Able was
sent directly towards the last known coordinates
of the now-deceased MTF, deep in the heart
of the Lacandon Jungle.
Sat atop a tree as the aircraft made its approach,
the creature had lowered its cloaking device,
certain it was alone as it polished a skull
it had collected from one of the ill-fated
operatives.
The Predator was a member of a species called
the Yautja, one of the few details about its
race that DiLiegro’s files hadn’t mentioned.
Everything else was accurate though, it was
indeed a hunter, here to claim trophies as
proof of its skill; these trophies happened
to be the skulls and spines of whatever it
killed.
Hearing the sound of an incoming vehicle,
the Predator instinctively reached for a control
on its left wrist gauntlet.
Its cloaking device reactivated, bending the
light away from itself to render the alien
hunter nearly invisible.
Through the lenses of its bio mask, the Predator
watched the craft pass overhead, and the shape
of a single, humanoid heat signature dropping
from it and landing in the rainforest.
Trekking through the lush vegetation, Able
walked towards the location he had been given.
It always irked the immortal barbarian when
the Foundation attempted to use him to perform
their menial dirty work.
To Able, such tasks were beneath him.
But he had been promised a fight with a worthy
adversary, and that was the only reason he
had agreed to undertake this mission.
Looking around as he reached a clearing, there
was no sign of the MTF agents.
Until, that is, Able craned his neck upwards
and found them.
Something had meticulously gathered up the
bodies and hung them from the branches by
their legs.
It felt distinctly like a warning, as well
as a taunting gloat; every indicator pointed
to this being the action of a creature that
was marking its newfound territory.
With a wave of his hand, Able pulled a black-edged
sword out of a pocket dimension holding his
weapons, holding the blade at the ready.
Looking down, he saw three points of red light
had appeared on his bare chest.
Just as Able caught sight of the treetop where
the lasers were coming from, a bolt of high-energy
plasma was fired towards him.
Within the same split second, he hurled his
sword in the direction of his invisible enemy.
The blast struck him and knocked him down,
searing his flesh – not that Able could
feel the pain.
At the same time, his sword spun through the
air and cleaved through the branch where the
Predator had been perched, causing the creature
to drop to the jungle floor with a thud.
As the Yautja stood up, it noticed its gauntlet
was sparking, having sustained damage in the
fall.
Now, its cloaking device was flickering on
and off.
The Predator knew it would need to repair
its equipment, but first and foremost needed
to collect a trophy from its latest kill.
The creature strode towards where Able was
laying, a scorch mark left by the plasma caster
burned into his flesh.
Its cloaking device still malfunctioning,
the hunter reached down to claim its prize…
Able’s eyes suddenly snapped open and caught
the creature by surprise.
Reeling his leg back, he delivered a sharp
kick that sent the Predator hurtling backward,
despite it being well over seven feet tall
and five-hundred-and-twenty pounds of armor
and alien muscle.
Able hurriedly stood back up, facing off against
the alien warrior as it too drew itself to
full height.
The gauntlet on its left wrist continued to
spit sparks, until the Predator reached a
clawed digit over and pressed a control.
With an electronic bleep, the cloak deactivated
fully, and the hunter was revealed.
It was tall, standing on two legs like a man.
It seemed lithe and agile but clearly almost
as strong as Able himself, judging by how
muscular it was.
Long appendages resembling locks of hair protruded
from its head, behind a metal faceplate, a
mask covering the true face of the creature
below.
A clicking, chittering noise emanated from
beneath the Predator’s bio mask, as it reached
for a sash that went across its front, and
produced a pair of small metal circles.
Able flexed his shoulders and ran at the creature.
The Predator hurled both its disks at Able,
curved blades extending from both of them
as they spun through the air.
Able ducked out of the path of one shuriken,
narrowly dodging the second as he charged
at the alien hunter.
Reaching for its back, the Predator produced
the long, ornate handle of its combi stick.
Both ends of the telescopic spear extended
and the hunter began racing forward to clash
head-on with its newfound prey.
It plunged the spear right through Able with
all of its strength, lifting the barbarian
off his feet on the end of its weapon.
Out of nowhere, SCP-076 produced another of
his swords, the Predator turning to look in
confusion at the weapon that had seemingly
just appeared in the hand of what it had taken
for an ordinary human.
Catching the off-world game hunter by surprise,
Able swept the sword through the air, cleaving
the creature’s spear in two, causing him
to drop back to the ground, landing on his
feet.
Following it with a second, swift swing of
his blade, Able brought the weapon down in
a slash that cut across the creature’s chest.
It sliced through the thick, reptilian hide
of the Predator, leaving a streak of oozing,
florescent green blood oozing from its torso.
The creature roared in pain, a sound like
the call of a lion echoing through the trees.
In retaliation, the Predator extended a pair
of blades contained in its right gauntlet
and swiped them at Able.
The wrist blades narrowly missed his face
as he dodged in incoming attack, only to be
caught by the creature’s other hand.
It gripped his head and plunged downwards,
knocking Able over and sending him face-first
into the rainforest floor.
Reaching for its cloaking device control,
the Predator disappeared, retreating into
the jungle to tend to its heavily bleeding
wound.
“What manner of devil is this creature,
Hall?”
Able yelled at the researcher over his earpiece,
hacking branches out of his path with his
sword as he followed the trail of luminous
green left by the wounded hunter.
“It’s a warrior from another world,”
Hall replied.
“A hunter that tracks its prey by their
body heat.
Considers itself honorable, but often likes
to go after more dangerous targets to challenge
itself.
Not unlike you, Able.”
“I am nothing like this demon!”
the barbarian shouted in fury.
“This gutless monster has no honor.
If it did, it would not give itself such an
unfair advantage, nor would it run away when
wounded.
A true warrior would be happy to die a warrior’s
death in single combat, and wouldn’t rely
on all its fancy weaponry.”
“Well, from what we can tell, these things
have their own code of sorts,” DiLiegro’s
voice said over the comms.
“You might not think of this hunter as honorable,
but it definitely thinks of itself that way.
Maybe use that to your advantage?”
“I do not need to be lectured by the likes
of you!”
Able interrupted.
“You have not known the heat of battle,
none of you at the Foundation have.
I will follow the trail of this cowardly beast’s
blood, and cleave its foul head from its shoulders!”
Unbeknownst to Able, high above on a branch,
the Predator was watching him.
Its bio mask had been zoomed in on him, the
hunter listening in to the barbarian’s outrage.
It turned to the task at hand, opening up
its MediKit and producing the surgical tools
within as it tended to the deep green cut
across its chest.
Stifling roars of pain beneath its mask, the
Predator stapled the injury closed and applied
a solvent to cauterize it.
Night was beginning to fall, and Able had
long since lost the trail of green blood.
Frustrated, he thought back to what the puny
researchers at the Foundation had told him
of his alien adversary.
If it believed itself to be honorable, to
have a code, then perhaps using that to lure
it out to face him might work.
With the sun rapidly disappearing beyond the
treeline, Able gathered a number of branches,
hacking them off trees with his sword and
fashioning them into burning torches.
He placed them in a circle around the circumference
of a clearing, creating a makeshift gladiatorial
arena.
He could feel his blood boiling, the urge
to defeat this monster making him seethe.
Throwing his head back and beating a fist
against his chest, Able roared up at the dark
sky.
“Come out, hunter!” he howled.
“Show yourself!
Come on, do it.
I’m right here!”
Watching him from afar, hidden by its cloak,
the Predator recognized what was happening.
This was a challenge, a direct call to engage
in single combat.
Refusing this challenge and shooting its prey
dead would be quicker, easier, but the hunter
knew it was being watched, and therefore judged.
With a growl, it dropped to the ground and
paced towards the circle.
Able turned as the Predator revealed itself,
appearing almost from thin air.
As it did, he drew one of his weapons and
stood ready to fight.
The hunter shrugged off the technology it
carried on its back, dropping the plasma caster
and the MediKit, before reaching up and pulling
off its mask.
Its face was grotesque, four hooked mandibles
surrounding its mouth, flared in anger.
“You are one ugly-” Able said, only to
be interrupted by the Predator extending the
blades from its gauntlet and letting out another
bestial roar.
Holding his sword aloft, Able gave a goading
beckon to his opponent as the pair of them
circled one another.
Finally, the creature gave in and lunged at
him, swiping its pair of razor-sharp serrated
blades at Able.
He swung his sword in at the last second,
deflecting the oncoming blow with a clang
of metal.
Reaching into his pocket dimension, Able pulled
a second weapon out in his other hand, and
swiped it at the Predator, slicing through
the creature’s hide and leaving another
gaping wound at its thigh.
Roaring in fury, the Predator launched another
strike.
Able blocked the attack yet again, this time
by crossing his swords, but the Predator barged
forward, driving its blades into its prey’s
chest and pinning his two weapons against
him.
The monstrous alien viciously head-butted
Able, the hooks of its mandibles scratching
his face as it did, before reaching up to
the back of his neck with its free hand.
Able could feel the sheer strength of the
hunter lifting him off his feet, ready to
twist his neck and pull his head off to claim
it as a trophy.
Kicking the Predator in the chest, Able used
the force of the impact to push himself free
from the creature’s grip, backflipping through
the air and landing a few feet away.
His swords clattered together as they dropped
to the ground, the immortal barbarian summoning
another and immediately charging at the Predator.
It had been winded by the kick, and barely
recovered in time to defend itself as the
blade swung for its neck.
The Predator staggered back, green blood oozing
from its hide and pouring from its mouth.
That blow had mortally wounded it.
It was bleeding heavily, and knew it might
not survive this hunt.
But it refused to be bested by a human, even
one as seemingly invulnerable as Able.
Hunching over, listening to him slowly approaching
to deliver the killing blow, the Predator
tapped a series of controls on its gauntlet;
a gradually-accelerating beeping began emanating
from the device.
Turning around at the last second, the alien
hunter impaled Able before he was upon it,
skewering SCP-076-2 on its wrist blades.
His sword had been raised above his head to
plunge through the creature, and even while
impaled, Able was able to deliver the final
blow.
Stabbing the Predator while it too had stabbed
him, the pair were locked in a stalemate,
angrily roaring at each other until an explosion
of energy burst from the hunter’s gauntlets,
reducing both Able and the Predator to atoms.
Watching from their satellite feed, Hall and
DiLiegro sighed.
They wouldn’t have their specimen for testing,
but at least they knew that Able would eventually
resurrect within the stone cube, SCP-076-1.
But even higher up than their satellite, someone
else was watching.
A group of Predators growled and chittered
amongst themselves, having witnessed from
their ship as one of their own had died in
battle with Able.
Although there was no way of knowing, the
noises the hunting party were making could
have been expressions of disappointment at
their fallen brother…
or a declaration of war.
Now go and check out “BOBA FETT VS SCP-610
THE FLESH THAT HATES”.
And afterwards, witness a battle between two
brothers in “SCP-073 & 076 CAIN VS ABLE”!